what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg and John here today we are prepping
to go to WonderCon right now it looks like we
found our topics for our panel yes it's gonna
be a fun one it's gonna be enjoy his occasion
no we're gonna have our owner comp panel talking
about the current state of the MCU and DCU
fandom with that while searching there was
two stories that were consistently popping up on
our feeds the reasons are obvious as to why that
would be the case we're going to talk about
two things today one these Harley Quinn Lady
Gaga set photos and another story which is very
much connected to the same thing this one is like
now completely overshadowing that one at the time
filming this Jonathan majors has been arrested so
um let's start with the positive one first
one more positive one right and then we'll
end this in a really dark place just a way that
you want to do your videos that's how you you
leave your audience feeling leave them on a bum
note but you guys can uh leave a like on your
way out so yeah these Harley Quinn said photos
I thought were pretty cool actually were these
outside of John outside of like a courthouse
and they're all protesting to free the Joker
there's a crowd gathered many clown masks Easter
eggs abound if you guys watch my trailer reaction
that I did for that 15 second teaser I gave a
plot Theory and I still feel like the movie is
going to be going down the path that I've been
predicting and seeing here they have like even
some video where I can't quite tell if she's being
escorted down the stairs or being escorted up the
stairs they're just resetting the tape there's
conflicting videos here I think he's gonna kill
it I feel like the second shoot was castle and
perfect casting Perfect cast especially for an
actress who takes her work methodically serious
will definitely be able to give a portrayal that
is in the universe of this Dark World of Joker
distinguish herself from what Margot Robbie's
been doing in live action and what you got
here is something that feels very natural and
doesn't feel overly heightened it looks kind
of like a ground I think about it looks kind
of like a cross between her as like quinzel and
uh Harley Quinn exactly taking the Harley Quinn
patterns and color palettes but applying it to
a more smart functional business attire kind of
approach yeah yeah something else that people
have been noticing images that they have that
are clearly not just in reference to Harvey Dent
they're about Harvey yes directly by name signs
that say Harvey Dent is a clown there's multiple
signs of that it would appear the way how Thomas
Wayne was utilized in the Joker movie that they
would probably utilize Harvey Dent that way like
I don't think he would become two-faced in this
film but I imagine district attorney Harvey Dent
will play role probably the one who keeps Joker
Behind Bars which would make sense if they're
saying Harvey Dent is a clown he's the one making
sure Arthur Fleck is being prosecuted then you got
quinzel who's probably the psychiatrist saying
like he shouldn't be left here or something like
that yeah yeah he should be criminally convicted
he should be put in some kind of Hospital put
into some kind of care and they probably want to
see him you know paid and hit with the book like
it also like the more we hear about this the more
it seems like maybe this could Arch into a bigger
franchise because I think it would be cool if we
got a just Harvey Dent presence in Folia do and
then wait till later to make him two-faced just
get the really deep two-faced one it's not even
like a messed up face yeah yeah that's just a bad
scholar yeah he's got like a Freddy Krueger bird
on half his face he's just really self-conscious
that's not a bad call it's not a bad Theory you
got there yeah what do you think about these
Harley Quinn set photos I think she looks great
and I I'm really excited for the direction that
this is going to end up evolving into John I think
it's only appropriate that you segue us into our
next topic uh but of course speaking of Smash Hits
Jesus Christ speaking of inappropriate
humor should I come out that stays in
the video oh good okay uh yeah no no
speaking of no laughing uh matters
Jonathan majors has been arrested in New York I
think we're gonna get in trouble let's say it's
in the video Even though I control the setting
I'm gonna decide okay every once in a while we
all need to be with our feet above the fire it
says these celebrities are a bunch of dumbasses
yeah yeah yeah I don't want to tell proven guilty
though I don't want to trivialize anybody's pain
it's interesting because there has been a tweet
circulating actually uh reposted today as a segue
somebody has posted that there's a particular
actor relatively new on the scene who Twitter
has violently Fallen head over heels for who's
actually a vicious cruel abusive human being both
professionally and in his personal life and every
new viral thirst tweet about him drives me insane
people have been reposting that and the person
who posted that redid it today with a ding ding
ding so it's an interesting uh development here
because Jonathan Majors obviously has this sort
of beloved personality and this is the last thing
you would want to hear about someone who stars on
the rise in the way that his has been but yeah
he has apparently been arrested and I guess let
go as of the moment uh you know for assaulting
somebody in a New York taxi cab yeah the way the
story goes according to um the highly respectable
TMZ the way the story goes is that while in a cab
major Major's girlfriend and all this is alleged
we got to keep that in mind it's all legends a
woman was texting him he did not respond kindly
to that grabbed her hand and slapped her allegedly
put her hands around her neck and supposedly
the resources that say the alleged victim had
invisible injuries including a laceration behind
her ear redness and marks to her face yeah these
are pretty serious charges Jonathan Majors reps
say that he did nothing wrong so pretty much it
was not what happened and let's not do this
we look forward to clearing his name I know
there was a time where whenever something came out
people immediately presumed this person was guilty
you know and I don't want to spend so much time
speculating as a matter of fact there's a reason
why putting both stories here in this one video
because we don't have a [__] ton of thoughts on
any of this yeah and this situation right here we
just gotta wait to see how it unfolds it's really
unfortunate yes as a fan of Jonathan Majors it
is saddening especially if this is true like it's
a really messed up situation and it's a really
messed up action if he actually did do this and
should be condemned for it you know but we did
letters or Miller ago so we might as well just
uh watch the next you know King Dynasty movie oh
yeah yeah we got money to make don't forget that
the bottom line but more importantly if it is
true um whomever this woman is I feel terrible
for her because we know how situations like this
go if it ends up being true somehow in this whole
process and this whole journey she can still get
some type of heat a lot of negative attention oh
yeah purposely or just the fact that she's getting
attention for this in general it's replaying the
trauma and then you've got people who are going
to behave really ugly on top of that it's not a
pleasant situation all around I don't know what to
believe simply because we don't really have much
information right now however it's not the major
is something that we've talked essentially about
on this channel and um definitely got our DMS
asking thoughts about it so here's our thoughts
waiting to see what happens and we don't know
what that'll be but hopefully that people in the
healing process of this situation because you
know if it is true God damn it that is [__]
horrible if it's not true yeah the Matrix himself
has to deal with having that you know mark on his
name because now that it's out there it's never
not gonna be thought of exactly because there's
already a lot of people who would immediately
presume it is true and it's something that would
follow someone around even if it isn't I hope it's
not it's yeah it's a it's the last thing you want
to hear especially for somebody in this position
but all that aside yeah it's just the worst kind
of situation you could find yourself in and I have
to feel for anybody who's coming forward with a
you know a story like that because you know you're
going to be persecuted by people who love this guy
alrighty guys well what do you think about
this story I'm sure it's a fun thing to
engage on the internet about it sure leave
your thoughts down below other cooler talk
um yeah uh I think it's good to enter right here
um yeah and then really dark place and yes no we
don't need to go any further yeah just leave
it here yeah no need to shout anybody out in
the dark video no I don't I feel like that
would be unnatural uh let's let's call it
a day guys we're off to wonder being good
to each other we'll see you guys foreign